dans un an ce vaste chantier ressemblera
à cela un nouveau complexe de vingt
mille mètres carrés adossé au centre
commercial vélizy 2 montant de
l'investissement 130 millions d'euros
l'idée de l' architecture c'est qu'on
révèle le programme intérieur depuis
l'extérieur donc on a on identifiera le
cinéma parce que le cinéma bénéficiera
de cette espèce de grande bulle en verre
en fait rétro éclairé la nuit qui qui
qui symbolisera en fait de façon
iconique le cinéma avec ses 18 salles et
ses 3800 fauteuil il deviendra le plus
grand cinéma du sud ouest parisien
objectif pour la direction de vélizy 2
qu'il se place dans le top 10 des
cinémas français en terme de
fréquentation par rapport à aujourd'hui
un million de visiteurs supplémentaires
est attendu au cinéma qui va offrir aux
spectateurs une technologie avec des
grands volumes d écran xxl qui
permettront vraiment de profiter de
toute la programmation peut proposer le
groupe ugc donc des films en vod films
en vo et en vf de l'opéra qui pourrait
diffuser des retransmissions donc une
programmation beaucoup plus bas beaucoup
plus riche que ce qu'on peut proposer
actuellement la direction souhaite avant
tout apporter une dimension loisirs au
centre commercial existant
un espace détente avec 19 restaurants et
kiosques vient compléter ce projet on va
avoir une grande entrée est directement
on va arriver sur une place principale
avec tous ces restaurants qui vont créer
une atmosphère très cosy et le but c'est
vraiment qu'on vienne à vélizy 2 pas que
pour le shopping en 2017 le centre
commercial vélizy 2 a accueilli 14 7
millions de visiteurs un chiffre que la
direction espère bien augmenter avec
cette extension